i just felt you know based on the things
that have gone on with duane based on
his development and where he is
um
we're better off putting the ball in the
hands of guys that know our system a guy
that's been in our system for three
years uh backed up by a guy that's been
in the system before and and it's a
little bit more accomplished quarterback
this is not an indictment on on dwayne
as much as indictment on the situation
circumstances that we are in
you know he did not have the benefit of
otas and minicamp he didn't have the
benefit of four preseason games to work
through things and because of that he's
behind
um in his development in the system and
again it's it's an unfortunate situation
uh but you know as we go through the
first four games and look at them and
break them down and you know i visit
with the coaches talk to the coaches go
through the
the games with the coaches and the
things that happen
you know it's just one of those things
that that he needs more time
ron rivera head coach of the washington
football team explaining on wednesday
that dwayne haskins has been benched he
will be replaced by kyle allen a guy
that was traded from carolina played
some games last year when ron rivera was
the coach there and knows the system
haskins all goes all the way down to
number three on the depth chart he won't
even be active on sunday alex smith will
be active which is a story in and of
itself but chris
do you agree with this decision and is
it really dwayne doesn't know the system
or is it the coaching staff just doesn't
have faith in dwayne haskins well i mean
i think it's a little bit of both at
this point you know i think the fact
that
you know
you know first off ron rivera said it
it's the right way he's the like dwayne
haskins is a poster child of the guy
that got affected by covet 19. yeah a
young guy who came out early of college
only played one year of college football
i mean one year of college football
played a few games last year it was very
raw
we saw some good and that all made us
hopeful
but to not have an off season for a guy
as raw as he is yeah that really hurt
him and if you watch what they do on the
offensive side of the ball right now
yeah they can't they can't run the
normal offense i truly believe that
they're having to run the offense to
kind of manage dwayne haskins as they go
because he's kind of learning on the fly
and it's a very tough position for him
to be in i feel for him
let alone he's made some really bad
mistakes and some big moments that have
affected their football team and of
course he's been inconsistent too
whether that's bad decisions or just you
know
at times he can make some throws where
you go whoa look at that damn throw but
then he could throw a five yard out
route and you'd go man that looked like
it was so much work and so hard for him
and he missed the target by four feet
and so there's things he has to work on
there's no doubt about that and i i
understand them with the the benching i
do they were unable to really generate
any offense last week you know the our
the cleveland game the week before was
there it was there for them to be
to be had they were out playing the
browns he made crucial mistakes that
really helped the browns win the
football game and then even the arizona
game the week before they managed them
but he made some mistakes there too so i
get it they're gonna let him go back
digest the offense sit on the sidelines
see how to play football i don't think
they're giving up on him but they know
right now he's not the best guy in that
room and the best guy that can give them
a chance to win
but you know i i've always heard that
the best coaches
take what they have and adapt their
system
to the best players
i can't help but wonder whether or not
ron rivera
believes dwayne haskins isn't his best
option and this happens
quarterback
is there
coach
leaves
new coach comes in
new coach may not be a lead a believer
in the quarterback who's there that
happens all the time right and that may
be part of what's going on here remember
we heard some ambivalence from ron
rivera about dwayne haskins back in
january right and i thought maybe this
is just kind of a way to
to
get dwayne haskins to not take anything
for granted to not get complacent to get
himself in the right kind of shape the
right kind of mindset and he did yeah
transformed his body he did but at some
point you got to perform and you got to
perform to the satisfaction of the
people who are getting paid to make the
decision as to who the best players are
who should be on the field and here's
the thing this isn't giving up on the
season this is acknowledging at one and
three they're a half game out of first
place that's got a chance yeah if they
can get quarterback play that doesn't
include so many turnovers maybe with
their defense they can win enough games
to steal that division still i i think
that's exactly the thought you're right
the defense is they're special i mean
it's it's a special group it's really
good you know all the way through and
they are the type of like defense and
team that they don't need a ton of
offense they just need an offense that
can be a little consistent and not put
them in tough spots with bad turnovers
and short fields
and they can play with just about
anybody and that's where haskins has
been killing them and you know mike your
question is very good like when you say
you know isn't it the job of the coaches
to kind of figure out what the player
does and does best i think we're at a
point here with this guy
he's so raw
and still so much in the you know
infancy stages of learning the offense
and doing all those things to where
you know i i don't even i i would
imagine and it just looks like to me
there's things that he's messing up that
they just go well
he doesn't know where his hot route is
he doesn't know he's supposed to check
this protection and get this guy blocked
and those type of things to where
yeah we like his talent and all that but
you know there's just a mental part of
the aspect in the game and it's his
second year in the nfl and it's his
second system and it's a totally
different system to where it's going to
take a second especially for a guy like
we said who is not like a you know
justin herbert or a tua or some of the
other quarterbacks we've seen come in
the last few years who have played a ton
of college football and had a ton of
reps that's where it was very weird it
was a one-year guy
who you know did special things but they
even managed them at ohio state so that
just tells you a little bit how raw he
is they made it very simple for him
there and he can throw it and stand in
there and do those things it's the other
stuff he just got to get a little more
nuanced at
but here's the reality
if he was asked to do last year and this
year what he did at ohio state
he'd be better at it
case in point kyler murray it's not like
they brought kyler murray to the nfl and
said hey we got a different system for
you that you got to learn oh and then
next year you got to learn a different
system than the one that you learned
last year yeah it's different than the
one that you played okay in oklahoma if
you give him the same system isn't that
what we've learned about this embrace of
young quarterbacks find the things they
did in college
and have them do those things in the nfl
and it feels like dwayne haskins isn't
getting the benefit of that with this
idea that he's going to learn a system
that's different than what he he ran at
ohio state and you know i feel like
chris this kyle allen thing is is very
temporary i'm going to put the over
under at one and a half games right he
was 30th in passer rating last year he
played 13 games yeah 30th and passer
rating and he was tied for fourth with
16 interceptions
despite only playing those 13 games
right i think we're gonna see alex smith
we're going to see when when they when
they're they are they they want to put
alex smith in uniform they want to put
him through the paces in practice for a
week or two of being the backup before
they make him the starter i think their
preference deep down would be go
straight to alex smith but they just
want that one this is just my guess they
just want that one little extra piece of
evidence to make them believe we put him
out on the field he's going to be able
to protect himself yeah he's not going
to have a serious injury like the one
that he had a couple of years ago yeah i
mean i i don't doubt that at all i mean
all right so there's two things i want
to comment on you know first off i just
want to take it back to the dwayne
haskins things and what you said there
too you know
even for
your points are right like kyla murray
everything you're saying there dwayne
haskins though
it was it was so basic even at ohio
state i don't think you could get away
with it in the nfl right that's that's
all i'm trying to say to where it's hey
let's have seven men block seven men
block and we just send out two or three
receivers you know they could get away
with at ohio state because they were
more talented than the other football
teams and then oh you want to stop the
pass and then oh well you know here's jk
dobbins or one of our other you know
awesome running backs so you're they
could get away with it to where the nfl
you can incorporate it but you're not
going to be able to run your offense
that way so that's that's that's the
predicament they're stuck in with kyle
allen i mean i i hear you i mean it
seems like alex smith would really be
the perfect quarterback for this team i
mean he is a guy that's going to take
care of the ball he'll let he'll he'll
play through the defense and the bigger
picture of what the team is so i get
that kyle allen did some good things
last year you know let's not forget that
it did fall apart a little at the end
but he came in as a starter taking over
for cam newton and won five out of six
football games
was up there in green bay in a close one
score football game where they could
have won the new orleans game they were
very close you know there so they he he
showed some positive signs is what i'm
saying
we'll see where it goes he does know the
offense terry mclaurin's a superstar the
the gibson kid at running backs pretty
good they got a decent o line well you
know like you said if they could just
take care of the ball i think they can
hang in there with just about anybody
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports